The 800-year-old city of Munich is a major international business center.
Munich was once known as the German Rome.
It's the third largest city in Germany and the capital of the State of Bavaria.
Munich's history dates back to the 9th century,...
...but during World War II, some 60% of it was bombed.
Since then, it's been re-created along the same architectural lines...
...and it's been done so well,...
...it's hard to tell the difference between the old and the new.
The city is marked with regal squares and streets...
...and magnificent residences, parks, and gardens.
The heart of Munich is located in the city's center.
Here in Marienplatz,...
...royal weddings and public executions took place centuries ago.
Today, the area that surrounds the city hall...
...is more characterized by sidewalk cafes and shops.
The squares themselves are venues for entertainment...
...with free browsing for enthusiasts of art and music.
A tourist information booth is located at the city hall in Marienplatz.
Get detailed maps and information on the many attractions...
...including museums that have some of the best collections in Europe.
Another lovely escape into history...
...is to the exquisite gardens of the Nymphenburg Palace,...
...once the summer residence of Bavarian sovereigns.